pedro asks what's your best tip for time
management
pijl actually I don't know MA my tip for
time management is to have an assistant
who you make the Czar of your time and
there's a let's go find map tomato
actually let's get it let's get out of
the cube a little bit let's see if we
can find de Maio
so for me the time management is
humanely scale what I basically do is I
find a human being that allows me to do
it and so in this scenario that dude is
my that's my answer for time management
putting human being who actually is the
czar Matt would you say you're the Czar
of time ah I might be a bit much but I'm
good with it
and so you know he knocks on the window
and says your next meeting and he texts
me and he's like are you on this call so
that's what I do I use human beings
obviously using a human being to manage
your time it's not very practical for
most of the audience so I'm going to try
to give some practicality which is I
really don't know because prior to using
a human being I didn't really have a
great system obviously we have
technology now like phones that buzz you
and Google calendars I don't know how
people do it I just think it becomes a
religion I decided my time was worth a
lot to me and I created infrastructure
around it for me was humans for you it's
got to be something that reverse
engineers your actual behavior